hi there this is steve kaufman again uh
i'm going to do a little uh video here
on memory
this is a request from one of my viewers
wakako
um
what do i consider to be the role of
memory in language learning
i'd like to start with an example that i
got from um
oscar one of our link members in spain
we just had a conversation in spanish
and we talked about memory and he said
you know it's a bit like driving a car
when we drive a car
we do everything automatically because
we have
basically ingrained the the
habits the patterns all the things we
need to do in order to drive a car we do
them automatically and we can't remember
the last 10 minutes of our ride what we
did how we
you know signaled or turned or breaked
or changed gears or whatever it might be
and i think language learning is a bit
like that let me think of some other
things that relate to memory um i read
somewhere that they did a test with a
group of
two groups of 20 language learners
and the first
group was given a list of
whatever 20 30 words to learn
to study
and the second group was not given that
list then they were asked to read a text
and there was no difference in the
ability of these two groups to read
this text this was in the language that
they were learning and and so i mean
what was
being pointed out in that study was that
being confronted with a lot of things to
remember
we don't necessarily remember them very
well
um
you know i have the experience when i
read sometimes for my russian study i'll
read a play by chekhov
and at the beginning of the play they
introduce all of the
people who are in the play the general
and his daughter and so so-and-so and
his wife and
and of course as soon as i start reading
the play i can't remember who's who
i know that when i look up words in a
dictionary uh no sooner do i look up the
words then i've forgotten what the
meaning was
so
i think memory is not a very good thing
to rely on when speaking
sort of to review because it's a bit
like driving the car you have to be able
to produce these words and phrases
automatically on the fly
when we're driving i don't think we rely
on memory i don't think we try to
remember something we read in a manual
um
you know when i'm reading the play it's
only after i've read the play
quite a way through the play and i start
to become comfortable with the
characters in the play
occasionally referring back to the list
of characters that that i become
comfortable with who
who is who in the play
uh
similarly with
with uh words you know it's only when
i've seen the words in different
contexts that they start to stick
so
i think what we're dealing with in
language learning is more a matter of
establishing certain patterns in the
brain
so that initially things are new
primarily words and phrases and
gradually these become
patterns
uh and the way the patterns are formed
is either
it's i think it's a combination of
of uh you know the brain
kind of
absorbing a lot of input and starting to
form its own patterns based on what it
hears
but i think the brain also
tries to rely on some logic that the
brain has
and
one good example is
my favorite example of the third person
singular in the present tense of english
it's the only one that changes i go you
go he goes
uh he went they went uh you know but
he talks she talks so that always
changes
and yet i would think that amongst
even some very proficient speakers of
english even some native speakers of
english
he don't go
um
you know uh
people continue to make that mistake
because the the brain is saying
the pattern is that this should be the
same as all the others
and it's very difficult to remember by a
memory
that the third person singular is the
only one that's different
uh
so i see language learning more as a
matter of
of gradually
getting used to something and allowing
the brain to form the necessary
patterns and this requires a lot of
exposure
you know tables i have tried in german
in russian to memorize
the tables i mean i don't have it handy
here i'd show you i've printed out the
list i even tried
rather than having the list based you
know for every
say none i'm talking about declensions
of nouns
rather than having the list for
masculine feminine neuter in the
different cases i i actually tried to
write a table where i would write the
ending ooh
and or uh
whatever it might be oi and then all the
nouns and the different cases and
genders that correspond to that ending
so rather than starting with the oneness
all of this stuff would have
very short term
influence on me
so so where i end up is that
we're not talking memory so much in
language learning
uh i think what we're talking about is
two things
uh three in fact i get back to the what
i call the golden trinity of language
learning
attitude
time on task
and attentiveness
those are the three things not memory
memory doesn't make it into the
golden trinity so you want to learn the
language you like the language you think
you can do it
you can visualize yourself as a speaker
of the language so you got all of that
you're not afraid of it you're not
resisting it you're not asking why do
they do it that silly way so your
attitude is positive that's number one
number two you're willing to spend a lot
of time
listening reading listening while doing
the dishes reading when you have a
chance
on the internet newspapers television
whatever it may be you're willing to put
a lot and talking to people to put a lot
of time into the language so that's two
time so attitude time and the third one
is attentiveness
noticing things you have to notice now
how do we notice i mean we've all had
the experience that when westerners go
to let's say japan they think all the
japanese look alike
japanese people have told me that they
think all westerners look alike
because
initially they're just different so we
don't notice the individual differences
we just see they're different
and after having when i lived in japan
for nine years i found that foreigners
all looked alike and the japanese looked
quite different from each other because
i spent most of my time looking at
japanese people so so that i had
therefore
sort of a a background
against which to notice things
and the same is true in language
learning when we first hit the language
everything is very strange we don't
notice any we don't notice much except
that it's very strange and we start to
learn a few words again
my favorite approach is to repetitively
listen to limited content initially and
then i start to
notice things i start to you know save
words and phrases in link i review them
in flash cards i find the flashcarding
is good because i noticed not only the
word and the word ending but i noticed
the phrase that was captured and i i
might edit my phrase in link so that i'm
spending time on it it's all helping me
notice
and as i have more knowledge and more
familiarity as the brain has been
exposed to more and more of it i start
to notice things that i didn't notice
before
and so uh as we become first of all i'm
motivated to learn
i'm spending the time i'm trying
deliberately to notice i'm trying to
notice when i read i will underline
certain phrases i will underline certain
cases
uh i will review them in my flashcards
which i really like doing now that i
have them on my ipod touch it's become
just about my favorite activity i think
it's really neat doing that
using the words and phrases that were in
the text that i had just reviewed
uh so i'm cultivating this ability to
notice to be attentive to direct my we
have to he even for pronunciation we
have to hear it we have to notice how
people pronounce
but for words for rules of grammar for
all of these things i don't think we can
rely on memory
i think we have to rely on
trying to notice
within the context of a lot of exposure
and
of course that we're motivated so
memory i don't think is a big deal i
don't think people who have good
memories are good language learners i
don't think musicians are good language
learners i don't think engineers are
good language learners because they can
understand grammar i think it's a matter
of paying attention getting enough
exposure and really wanting
to do it so there you have it as i run
out of time that's my view on the role
of members